though unquestionably in the minority
anti-monarchy voices were heard on
Coronation Day even by the king and
queen as the gold State coach passed
Trafalgar Square
the police say they had no intention of
silencing these protests and expressed
regret for what happened earlier in the
day the arrest of six people preparing
to take part the anti-monarchy group
Republic had prior permission to hold a
protest but as the group's leader and
others unpacked their placards that
morning the police moved in acting on
the mere suspicion that protesters
intended to lock on or attach themselves
to objects or each other this is a
demonstration of what happens when you
have incredibly Broad overreaching and
Draconian legislation rushed through
with limited scrutiny and that creates
new and expansive Powers including new
offenses of locking on going equipped
for locking on expanded stop and search
powers in the protest context as well as
protest Banning orders that together
creates what one parliamentary committee
is called a hostile environment for
protests
really holding a banner in Westminster
and I'm being arrested for my actions
dozens of arrests were made that day
some apparently arbitrary the
Metropolitan Police say they were acting
on intelligence that different protest
groups intended to disrupt the
coronation in deciding to take no
further action against the Republic six
however the police have essentially
admitted they made a mistake a
metropolitan police statement says they
searched the vehicle and as well as a
large number of placards found items
which at the time they had reasonable
grounds to believe could be used as
lock-on devices the investigation has
been unable to prove intent to use them
to lock on and disrupt the event
even through the cries of not my king
the coronation was an enormous event
that passed largely without incident for
which says the government the police
should be congratulated as for the
arrests for the responses to stress that
the police are operationally independent
of the government nothing in other words
to do with us they make the decisions on
the ground in the way that they see that
that's the way that we've always done it
that's the right way to do it it
wouldn't be right for me to interfere
with their operational decisions that's
a line that is coming under increased
scrutiny especially since it was the
government that rushed these
controversial policing Powers through
Parliament just days before the
coronation Jonah Al Jazeera London
foreign